licite chance qu est encore sous
contrôle l'ukrainien mais cette ville
d'udon basse est une cible de l'armée
russe les bombardements ils sont
quotidiens sans eau courante
les habitants s'en remettent aux camions
citernes
on reçoit de l'eau ici pour faire du
linge et la vaisselle pour l'eau potable
on l'apprend d'une source mais il est
difficile d'y aller la pente est raide
elle est bombardé tous les jours il faut
donc aller sous les bombardements et les
tirs
face aux dangers et aux difficultés
croissantes
cette femme c'est finalement décidé l
attention évacuation
les bombardements ont fait partir et
puis mon petit fils m'a supplié grand
mère vient chez nous mais je ne sais pas
où aller j'ai perdu
des convois sont régulièrement organisés
pour partir 19 familles sont volontaires
ce jour si tu dis moi ce qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes à une nouvelle étape de
l'évacuation des citoyens donné cette
chance qu il est très difficile de
persuader les gens que l'offensive
atteint un point critique
mais il est grand temps pour eux de se
décider à évacuer ce nom mais c'est en
face de licite chance la ville de sévir
au donetsk où les combats font rage les
soldats ukrainien résiste mais les
russes contrôlent qu'une majeure partie
de la cité selon les autorités locales
dans toute la région de nombreux
ukrainiens doivent vivre dans leur cave
tous ceux qui n'ont pas pu être évacuées
ou qui ont refusé de partir